got to this point so there's this
perfect sort of cliffhanger at the end
of this season of Silicon Valley that
kind of is a like what will happen to
Erlich you know he will he come back
and I thought television unlike wine and
women does not get better with age and I
got in a in a series where it's very
cyclical in terms of they failed and
they succeeded in to successfully find
failure and they failed on the you know
data success I was like wouldn't one of
the cliffhangers would if suddenly this
is the end of this character and HBO
came back to me because I'm so busy my
schedules so crazy so exhausting so
dangerous actually health-wise boga that
they were like we had to move production
around for you a couple times so you
know we want to offer you a different
deal to do maybe five out of the ten
episodes or seven but legally by doing
that they gave me the option to say no
to walk the show which they never
thought I would do because they thought
that I am a television actor or just an
actor and an actor would never leave a
television not a jeweler yet and
especially one that's that popular and
has that much of a following and so I
thought that was the most interesting
thing to do for the show because now I
have to change it and HBO was lately
couldn't believe it they were like well
wait wait wait what did you want to do
three of us if you even do don't leave
the show did they think you were trying
to bluff to get all ten um now okay
because they know because they went
right back and they were like we'll do
what it ever takes to like you know do
you want to promise us you'll would you
be open to a season finale I was like no
it's so much more interesting if this is
the end of that character and the show
has to change it has to grow it's my
judge not only going to figure out a way
I mean Christopher and Welch died in the
first season and they figured out a way
to make the show as good as it is
possibly I don't think it I think it
would have been funnier with him but so
they'll figure they'll figure that out
and even Mike judge he called and to
look you know you sure you don't want to
do any
we just figure out and by the end of the
conversation kind of went yeah that's I
mean yeah you know I sort of wanted to
leave because a Butthead that's right in
the movie because I want to leave
earlier than not MTV did so I guess you
know I'd probably do the same by the end
of it he even he was sort of admitting
that creatively it's going to do
something to the show and that something
isn't going to be anything positive
right and it gave me this opportunity to
tell Kate something make a very strong
statement to her which is that I'm not a
liar because for years I remember we've
nature that's like 14 years four years
I've been saying the schedule is going
to slow down I'm going to do less you
just have to understand I have to sprint
right now right before I can bring it
down to a jog it just requires this much
work and by this much I mean like every
single night performing every single day
having something weekend's there's
always interviews it's just always
something F or something and so I was
able to say to her look I'll walk from
the most stable most kind of important
big chunk of time that I'm doing this
show I'm going to clear that out
completely in be in New York City where
your world is where you are where we can
otherwise it's like in the winter we're
basically in a long-distance
relationship while I'm doing the show
because she stays in New York and I'm in
Los Angeles and that's just a terrible
[ __ ] way to [ __ ] my live out there at
all now I mean she you know she stays
with me almost the entire time but then
she's not doing anything but it's like
just my life you know